I'm hoping to understand the right machine even more. Sometimes in the night when I wake up,
the light is very warm. Should I be concerned? No. So different frequencies, the light is going to
heat up more than at other frequencies, number one. And if you have less circulation, meaning you
happen to be laid on the bulb, you happen to be holding a tight, you happen to be,
having to be under the covers, the situation with where the bulb was placed at that given time
would also not allow air circulation and could result in a hotter bulb. There's no concern with
that. That itself is not going to burn out the bulb. Also, I wonder if I should be repositioning
the light along my body throughout the week. I've been keeping it near my chest every night.
As I am treating breast cancer, I would keep doing exactly what you're doing. I always think
that it's best even though you're going to get adequate treatment even if the bulb is a foot away
from you or even the even couple feet away from you, you're going to get better treatment
the closer it is to you and it makes sense to have it even closer to the area in question. So
I would keep it right. If you have breast cancer and that's what you're treating, I would be
stuggling it as best you can right over your breast.